[Music]
the lifeblood of the russian economy is
now the newest front in the war we're
banning all imports of russian oil and
gas and energy
the u.s is the latest country to turn
off the taps to russian oil and gas it
follows the lead of canada and adds
pressure on european nations to do the
same americans have rallied to support
the ukrainian people and made it clear
we will not be part of subsidizing
putin's war russian imports make up just
a small fraction of energy supplies in
north america but they're king in europe
where governments are less willing and
less able to move away from their
dependence on moscow we can't move
overnight but we can certainly do it and
we can do it in a way that doesn't
disrupt supply the uk says it hopes to
stop all russian oil and gas imports by
the end of 2022
the eu wants to cut russian gas imports
by two-thirds before the end of the year
it will take until 2030 to phase out in
full it's hard
bloody hard
but it's possible if we're willing to go
further and faster than we've done
before yet no one knows if it will work
to stop vladimir putin or his war
machine as the russian economy suffers
more and more
as these the
sanctions
they start biting
that's where we need to be watching how
putin responds the response so far has
been to inflict pain on western
consumers the kremlin says it might soon
cut off natural gas supplies to europe
and russia claims that oil prices could
suddenly double without access to its
markets at a time when consumers are
paying record amounts for fuel at the
pumps
that hasn't stopped the newfound resolve
to end the world's dependence on russian
energy as far as i'm concerned gas
prices are irrelevant the only thing
that matters is that we take a stand
long considered a security risk it's now
a moral one as well jackson prosco
global news washington